[Musik]
der Geburtstag Israels wird jedes Jahr
mit einer Demonstration der Stärke
gefeiert Kampfjets am Himmel senden die
Botschaft dieses Land beherrscht jeden
Konflikt währenddessen feiern die
Israelis auf ihre typisch lässige Art
das 75 Jubiläum der Staatsgründung
können stolz auf den erreichten
Wohlstand sein und hadern doch mit den
ungelösten Konflikten mit einigen
Nachbarn gibt es Frieden mit den aller
nächsten den Palästinensern bis heute
nicht immer wieder bricht der gewaltsame
Konflikt auf dazu die Konflikte im
Inneren um ultraorthodoxe und
extremistische Zionisten
hunderttausende demonstrieren gegen
deren Pläne zur Schwächung der
Demokratie was ist aus dem Traum vom
Staat der Juden geworden ein Land so
zerrissen wie nie in seiner Geschichte
[Musik]
sie sind Israelis aber sie leben im
besetzten Westjordanland wie hier bei
mir in der Nähe von nahtlos entstehen
dort jedes Jahr neue nach
internationalem Recht illegale
Siedlungen die Zahl der israelischen
Siedler liegt inzwischen bei über
700.000
als ich hierher kam gab es vielleicht
100 Juden ich sehe hier zwei Millionen
Juden 3 Millionen Juden viele Millionen
mehr Juden das ist meine Vision
unterwegs mit Daniela weiß eine der
frühen SiedlerInnen und Lobbyistin der
Siedler Interessen sie hat 1975 mit keum
eine der ersten Siedlungen mit gegründet
und betreibt seitdem als Aktivistin
konsequent die jüdische Besiedlung des
Westjordanlandes
es ist ein Wunder was ich hier vor mir
sehe weil hier neue wohntrailer für neue
Familien und eine neuen Outpost
angekommen sind Ihre Kamera sieht das
als erste
illegalen Außenposten den eine Handvoll
Familien in Windeseile errichtet die
Siedler müssen schnell sein nicht immer
aber manchmal versucht die Armee solche
Vorposten wieder zu räumen aber Sack ist
mit dem 5 Kind schwanger ihr Mann ist
bei der Armee das hier zieht sie fast
allein durch aber mit voller Überzeugung
wir sind hier eindeutig auf dem Gebiet
des Staates Israel es ist zwar etwas
seltsam so ein Haus zu sehen du würdest
wohl nicht darin leben wollen ohne Strom
und ohne Wasser
in der Welt der Siedler gibt es keine
Bedenken keinen Zweifel dass ihre
landname Unrecht sein könnte
the reasonic ist
die Rechtfertigung ist eine religiöse
wir bekamen das Versprechen von Gott an
unsere Vorväter Abraham Isaak und Jakob
dass das Land Israel von Anfang an den
Nachfahren unserer Vorväter gegeben wird
und der jüdischen Nation
für immer
ich brauche mir keinen bedeutenderen
Grund auszudenken als die Bibel
[Musik]
möglich wurden die Siedlungen erst durch
den sechs Tage Krieg von 1967 von allen
Kriegen die Israelis und Araber führten
wird dieser am stärksten nach Israel
eroberte Ost Jerusalem Gaza und das
Westjordanland Gebiete die nach dem
unteilungsplan von 1947 größtenteils den
Palästinensern zustehen für viele
Israelis aber rückte auf einmal die
Wiederherstellung des biblischen Israels
in den Bereich des Möglichen
natürlich Jerusalem das hatte so eine
Tragweite dass man nun wieder vereint
war mit dem Tempelberg der Klagemauer
die berühmten Bilder von 1967 mit den
Soldaten an der Mauer für viele Israelis
waren das Tief emotionale und geradezu
metaphysische Momente sogar für komplett
säkulare Menschen wir lassen das
Königreich auferstehen das vor 2000
Jahren verloren gehen
mit den Jahren wurde die Besatzung zum
Dauerzustand ein Friede zweier Staaten
rückte in immer weitere Ferne
stattdessen siedelten immer mehr
nationalistische Zionisten in den
besetzten Gebieten ihr religiöses
Sendungsbewusstsein von einem groß
Israel ist heute stärker denn je
Palästinenser spielen in dieser Vision
eines Gottesstaates unter jüdischer
Vorherrschaft nur eine untergeordnete
Rolle
Menschen die nicht akzeptieren dass sie
niemals Selbstbestimmung in Staat und
Land der Juden haben werden diese
Menschen müssen in die arabischen Länder
auswandern wo sie unter arabischer
Herrschaft leben können
das ist eine sehr klare Formel so steht
es in der Bibel danach lebe ich und
danach leben die Juden
das Gewalt nicht nur von Palästinensern
ausgeht sondern in vielfacher Form auch
von Siedlern streitet Daniela weiß
kategorisch ab my
people ich meine die jüdischen Leute
sind nicht gewalttätig sie predigen
niemals Gewalt wir haben hier eine
Synagoge wir haben hier 20 Synagogen
alles was sie dort hören ist Frieden
Frieden Frieden deshalb gab es nie ein
Pogrom von Seiten der Juden wir fahren
jeden Tag nach huara ich meine Kinder
meine Enkel die gesamte Familie nie
hatten wir auch nur den Gedanken
jemandem weh zu tun
an der Hauptstraße zwischen nahtlos und
Ramada liegt die Kleinstadt sie ist
gerade einer der Hotspots in israelisch
palästinensischen Konflikt
israelische Soldaten patroullieren auf
den Straßen kontrollieren die wichtigen
Kreuzungen
die Israelis wollen dass ihre Kinder in
Frieden Sicherheit und Stabilität Leben
doch ich will dass meine Kinder so
lieben können ich sorge mich genauso um
die Zukunft meiner Kinder wie die
Israelis
die Armee hat die Zufahrt nach huara
gesperrt wieder mal nur Siedler mit
israelischen Kennzeichen dürfen rein für
Vierer Edi und seinen Supermarkt eine
Katastrophe seit Monaten beherrschen
Gewalt und Terror die Stadt das Geschäft
ist seither massiv eingebrochen
die Situation ist sehr schlecht
insbesondere die wirtschaftliche
wie Sie sehen besitze ich dieses große
Einkaufszentrum für Lebensmittel aber
heute habe ich kaum noch Kunden
der Verkauf ist um 80% eingebrochen
aufgrund von Aktionen der Siedler und
der israelischen Armee in huara
früher hatte ich 50 Angestellte jetzt
sind es nur noch 20
seit Monaten kommt es zu gewaltsamen
Übergriffen von sie dann auf
Einheimische die armee greift kaum ein
brauchen keinen Grund um uns anzugreifen
manchmal werfen sie ohne Grundsteine auf
uns
war eine Reaktion auf das was die
israelische Armee und die Siedler tun
vor einem Jahr noch hatten wir gute
Beziehungen zu den Juden und zu den
israelisra
[Musik]
auf der anderen Seite verüben
Palästinenser brutale Terrorangriffe
mitten in huara werden Ende Februar zwei
Siedler ermordet viele hier haben dafür
Verständnis
die Anschläge waren eine Reaktion auf
die israelischen Aktionen gegen
Palästinenser bei denen viele inner Plus
und Jean von der israelischen Armee
getötet wurden außerdem kam die
Attentäter gar nicht aus Hua
nach dem Anschlag entlädt sich die
Gewaltspirale in einer Explosion ein
wütender Mob aus sieht man sieht durch
huara und nimmt Rache Steine fliegen auf
Wohnhäuser und Geschäfte dutzende Autos
sind Häuser werden angezündet eine
Menschen Jagd ein Palästinenser wird
erschossen an die 100 verletzt die Armee
verliert völlig die Kontrolle oder will
nicht eingreifen versucht nach eigener
Aussage Menschen zu retten ein
israelischer Offizier spricht von einem
Pogrom
eine Überwachungskamera zeigt die
Siedler versuchen das Haus von Firas de
mai die anzuzünden auch Wochen nach dem
Gewaltexzess sind die Spuren davon noch
gut sichtbar
nach Hause wir versuchten das von den
Siedlern gelegte Feuer zu löschen Griff
uns die israelische Armee mit
Blendgranaten und Tränengas an
die Soldaten haben alles gesehen aber
nichts gemacht
am nächsten Tag kamen sie zu mir und
sagten warum bist du hier du sollst in
dein Land Jordanien oder Saudi-Arabien
zurückkehren das waren die Worte der
Armee zu mir
die führt uns auf das Dach seines Hauses
seine letzte Verteidigungslinie
diese Steine sind von den Siedlern damit
haben sie uns angegriffen wir behalten
sie um uns selbst vor den Siedlern zu
schützen wenn Sie uns noch mal angreifen
werden wir uns mit diesen Stein
verteidigen weil es niemanden gibt der
uns verteidigt
in diesem Konflikt trifft es Schuldige
und unschuldige aber Gewalt erzeugt
immer noch mehr Gewalt ein normales
Leben zu führen scheint da unmöglich für
sein Geschäft seine Familie und sich
selbst sieht immer Edi auf Dauer keine
Perspektive mehr
ich mache mir große Sorgen um die
Zukunft meiner Kinder ich sehe schwarz
für Sie ich stehe zwischen zwei feuern
entweder wir verlassen das Land in dem
wir geboren sind um die Kinder zu
schützen oder wir opfern unsere Kinder
damit wir im Land unserer Eltern und
Großeltern bleiben können wir sind dazu
bereit Israel versucht uns zu
terrorisieren damit wir dieses Land
verlassen
[Musik]
zu den äußeren Konflikten kommen die im
Inneren wie der um die jüdische
Identität
ultra-orthodoxe beanspruchen einen immer
größeren Einfluss auf das
gesellschaftliche Leben ihr Anteil an
der Bevölkerung derzeit bei 14 Prozent
wächst schnell beten ist ihr
Lebensinhalt in den Schulen studieren
Sie die Tore statt Englisch und
Mathematik zum Militär müssen Sie nicht
einer geregelten Arbeit gehen meistens
allenfalls die Frauen nach ein Leben in
einer Parallelwelt
ich bin sicher der Tag wird kommen an
dem der Messias erscheinen wird und wenn
er kommt werden wir von allen Problemen
erlöst wer den Weg der Thora gegangen
ist gewinnt wer nicht verschwindet
joelisch-kreuz hat 18 Kinder und sechs
Enkelkinder mit seiner Frau und den
Minderjährigen lebte auf engstem Raum im
Jerusalemer Viertel mehr cherin zwei
Zimmer und so etwas wie ein schlafkiller
ab und zu hat er Gelegenheit Jobs die
Familie lebt in prekären Verhältnissen
doch joelisch beklagt sich nicht Geld
vom Staat nehme er nicht sagte gerade
weil er auf materiellen Reichtum
verzichte seien er und seine Frau
glücklich
materielles umso besser kann man leben
jeder möchte immer mehr ich bleibe bei
dem wenigen was ich habe also brauche
ich auch nicht mehr
sobald du was besitzt möchtest du immer
mehr das hat kein Ende
joelisch gehört zur sogenannten Gemeinde
der gottesfürchtigen die lehnt den Staat
komplett ab sie hoffen auf den
Gottesstaat den der Messias nach seiner
Ankunft errichten werde
der starb Israel ist die größte
Katastrophe die dem jüdischen Volk
geschehen konnte
ich habe keine Wahl ich lebe hier weil
ich hier geboren bin und ich nicht weg
kann ich versuche damit zu leben nichts
vom Staat zu nehmen wenn du keinen
Kontakt mit ihm machst kannst du sicher
sein dass du orthodox bleibst
was zehntausende gottesfürchtige und
joelisch nicht davon abhält gegen die
säkulare Welt da draußen und ihre
sündhaften Accessoires zu protestieren
für sie gelten nur die Regeln des
Kaschrut die festlegen was koscher ist
und was nicht
Smartphones mit Internetzugang gehören
definitiv nicht zur koscheren Welt
ultra-orthodoxe dulden nur koschere
Handys die taugen allenfalls zum
telefonieren
das Internet Zeitverschwendung da gibt
es viele schlechte Sachen da fehlen
Anstand und Sitte stattdessen lauter
übler Ansichten man wird süchtig davon
da kann man nichts machen es gibt viele
Scheidungen deshalb man wird abhängig
man lebt nicht mehr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Ablehnung der modernen säkularen
Welt mündet nicht selten in
gewalttätigen Protest so richtet sich
der Zorn der gottesfürchtigen auch gegen
die Straßenbahn die durch ihr Viertel
fährt
und zuletzt gingen Geschäfte die
unkorschere Smartphones vertrieben in
Flammen auf
ein anderer Teil der ultra-orthodoxie
ist dagegen bereit und willens Politik
zu machen die Parteien chass und
vereinigter Tora Judaismus sind
Koalitionspartner von Premiere im
Gegenzug wäre Stimmen bekommen sie
Subventionen für ihre Gemeinden und Tora
Schulen Privilegien und Einfluss auf
religiöse regeln
schon bei Gründung Israels war der
Einfluss der ultra-orthodoxen so stark
dass die Gründer Ihnen viel Macht
einräumten aus Rücksicht keine
Verfassung festschrieben ein Fehler der
sich heute recht Ben Gurion Ben Gurion
sah das nicht kommen er dachte wenn er
den säkularen Zionismus fest etabliert
und den Staat so etwas fast heiligem
macht also zu einer Art zivilen Religion
dass dies ein guter Ersatz sein würde
dass da vielleicht ein paar
ultra-orthodoxe übrig bleiben würden ein
paar religiöse und nationalreligiöse
aber das wirklich nur am Rande
das säkulare Israel das vor allem in Tel
Aviv seine Heimat gefunden hat fühlt
sich von den Ultra religiösen immer
stärker eingeschränkt denen ist das
freizügige Leben in der Metropole am
Strand seit jeher ein Dorn im Auge
[Musik]
ich wünsche dem Staat Israel dass er
mehr von Frauen und Schwulen regiert
wird denn weder wie schwule noch die
Frauen interessieren sich normalerweise
für Kriege
[Musik]
ich wünsche dem Stab Israel zum 75 mehr
Toleranz und die Bereitschaft die
Meinungen anderer Menschen zu
respektieren
Roy und oh hat sind seit 14 Jahren ein
Paar im hippen Florentin einem der
angesagtesten Stadtteile von Tel Aviv
betreiben die beiden ein Geschäft für
Brautmoden die Idee kam oh hat vor zwölf
Jahren der Finger als Personal
bridechoper an als rechte Hand der Braut
die sich um alles kümmert Kleid Make-up
Schmuck Frisur heute stehen die
Brautkleider im Vordergrund aber nicht
irgendwelche
wir haben den Bräuten beigebracht Smart
Brights zu werden unser Studio besitzt
leider der teuersten Kleider Designer
Israels wir verkaufen diese Kleider für
die Hälfte des Preises anstatt das Kleid
nur einmal zu verwenden und danach in
Mülleimer zu schmeißen wird es zweimal
angezogen
der zweite Standbein ist oh oh eine
Beratungsfirma für die sogenannte
gemeinsame Elternschaft Roy und oh hat
bringen Männer und Frauen zusammen die
ein gemeinsames Kind großziehen wollen
ohne ein paar zu sein nach einer
künstlichen Befruchtung erziehen beide
Elternteile Ihr leibliches Kind
abwechselnd groß
das Modell vom Heiraten zerbricht mit
der Zeit heute verstehen wir das
heiraten und Kinder kriegen nicht
unbedingt miteinander verbunden sein
müssen sie können auch getrennt
voneinander sein
[Musik]
mit ihren Kindern Rene und Ray leben die
beiden selbst das Modell der gemeinsamen
Elternschaft eine Mutter zwei Väter die
sich abwechselnd um die beiden Kinder
kümmern und alle sind glücklich
wir sind zwei biologische Väter geil ist
die biologische Mutter von beiden bei
René ist oh hat der biologische Vater
bei Rey bin ich es
in ihrem unmittelbaren Umfeld ist das
kein Problem
[Musik]
ich frage die Kinder mal findet
irgendjemand in Schule oder Kindergarten
ist seltsam dass ihr Vater und Vater hat
[Musik]
dennoch gewalttätige Anfeindungen nehmen
landesweit zu
homophobe Einstellungen sind
gesellschaftsfähig geworden
[Musik]
in der liberalen Tel Aviv Blase spüren
wie das weniger auch wenn letzte Woche
Fenster homosexueller eingeschmissen
wurden und Gay Pride Flaggen verbrannt
wurden
aber wir müssen kämpfen um nicht zu
verlieren was wir bis jetzt erreicht
haben es sind religiöse Elemente die uns
zurückwerfen wollen
sie wollen liberale Gesetze zurückziehen
sie wollen die konversionstherapie für
Schwule einführen
und Medikamente für Transsexuelle nicht
mehr finanzieren oder anderes was wir
erreicht haben
vor allem aber sind treu und du hat
stolz darauf wie weit sie schon gekommen
sind ganz persönlich und in Israels
Gesellschaft
[Musik]
wir sind eine zentrale Säule der
israelischen Gesellschaft wir haben
Wurzeln in ihr geschlagen wir dienen
sogar im Militär wir sind ein wichtiger
Teil der israelischen Mischung
[Musik]
zur Mischung in Israel gehören auch die
kybodsim wie der in Jeron an der
Nordspitze Israels die Hügel am Horizont
sind schon Teil des Libanon gegründet
1949 ist jiron fast so alt wie der Staat
Israel und eine der wenigen kybodsim die
den Sprung in die Moderne geschafft
haben
ich wünsche Israel dass es wächst und
gedeiht und ich möchte den Leuten die
hier leben gute Dinge ermöglichen
unabhängig von ihrer Religion oder ihrem
Glauben
betreibt mitten im kyboots ein
Startup-Unternehmen mit seinen Drohnen
will er die Landwirtschaft
revolutionieren weltweit die fliegenden
roboter können Schädlinge erkennen oder
Fehler bei der Düngung und Bewässerung
und können selbst Pestizide auf
kleinstem Raum dosiert ausbringen
die Landwirtschaft durchläuft gerade
eine gigantische Revolution der Robotik
und der künstlichen Intelligenz heute
laufen Menschen durch Felder und sie
sehen ein paar Pflanzen vielleicht Hunde
eine Drohne aber schafft eine Million
Pflanzen in 20 Minuten wir können
Landwirtschaft also neu denken wie nie
zuvor
untergebracht ist das Start-up im alten
Kuhstall des kyboots der ist zugleich
größter Anteilseigner der Firma
[Musik]
wir sitzen in der alten Milchfarm seit
1949 der Stall für die Kühe hier werden
sie gefüttert
das ist das Gebäude es war mal der Stall
wo die Kühe gemolken wurden heute sind
wir die Kühe von der Milchfarm zur Tec
Farm
vom Kuhstall aus in Israels Provinz
berät das Unternehmen Landwirte auf
allen Kontinenten vielleicht liegt darin
das Geheimnis der Startup Nation Israels
Hightech Produkte machen rund 50% aller
exporter aus
Israel ist ein kleines Land wir haben
nicht so viel Wasser oder Land wir
können nicht die Welt ernähren aber so
wie wir vor 50 Jahren die
Tröpfchenbewässerung erfunden haben so
müssen wir uns jetzt die andere Stärke
Israels zu Nutze machen die
Hochtechnologie
noch baut der kyboots auch ganz
konventionell Obst und Wein an und bis
auf den Hightech-Bereich bekommen noch
immer alle den gleichen Lohn vom
Treckerfahrer bis hin zum altgedienten
Weinbauern doch der Umbruch bahnt sich
an als einer der letzten kyboots im Land
wird nun auch Hieron privatisiert nicht
zu ändern sagt Winzer anna war die
sozialistischen Ideale des urkybots
hätten sich überlegt
die Idee des keyboots ist eine
Gemeinschaft von Menschen die
miteinander kooperieren mit gemeinsamen
Aufgaben deshalb spielt das
wirtschaftliche Thema keine große Rolle
ab dem Moment an dem persönliche Gier
dazukommt wird es problematisch
dabei waren die ersten so etwas wie die
Keimzelle des Staates Israel
Ada Feinberg hat Hieron 1949
mitgegründet und lebt bis heute dort
später wurde sie Erzieherin gründete
eine Familie nach dem Schrecken des
Holocaust waren die Hoffnungen groß
genauso wie die Ansprüche
[Musik]
wir haben immer daran gedacht dass wir
nicht nur einen kyboots sondern einen
Staat gründen
denn das Volk Israel brauchte wie jedes
normale Volk einen Staat
wir hofften auf einen sozialistischen
einen guten und edlen Staat
doch diesem Staat droht ausgerechnet im
75 Jahr der Verlust des Guten des
demokratischen Kerns die Gesellschaft
zerbricht hunderttausende sind jede
Woche auf den Straßen um gegen die
Aushebelung der Gewaltenteilung zu
demonstrieren Menschen aus allen Teilen
der Gesellschaft Richter Beamte
Unternehmer Rentner Studenten Soldaten
noch nie hat sich in Israel ein so
breites Bündnis für ein gemeinsames Ziel
zusammengefunden viele waren vorher noch
auf keiner Demo doch es geht um nicht
weniger als die Demokratie an sich
ich wünsche mir in einem Land zu leben
das westliche Demokratie und
Liberalismus mit jüdischen Werten
verbindet beides verschmelzen lässt das
funktioniert großartig bis jemand
versucht das Ganze in zwei Teile zu
brechen
eigentlich hätte sich Israel schafier
ganz auf seinen altersruhe Sitz in Beet
uciel zurückziehen können und das tun
was der 70-Jährige Rentner am liebsten
tut zusammen mit Enkel matan seine
Olivenbäume hegen und pflegen der
hobbyland wird ist hoch dekorierter
Offizier und Pilot Rufname relig
Jahrzehnte hat er einem Land gedient das
jetzt auseinander fällt die Idee die
ideale und der soziale Zusammenhalt
spalten sich in Ideen auf die nichts
mehr miteinander zu tun haben
so wie die liberale Demokratie nichts
mit einem Gottesstaat einem orthodoxen
Gottesstaat zu tun hat oder gar der
Ausbreitung eines messianischen
Judaismus
für Israel hat relig viele
Luftschlachten geschlagen jetzt spürte
er erneut die Pflicht für sein Land zu
kämpfen
als Kampfpilot liegt es in deiner DNA
abzuheben und jegliche Bedrohung deines
Landes durch die Außenwelt zu stoppen
und jetzt wo ich 70 Jahre alt bin gibt
es eine andere Bedrohung dieses Landes
dieses Mal kommt sie von woanders her
von ihnen aber meine DNA bleibt dieselbe
und so findet man relig und seine
Kameraden von früher mindestens einmal
pro Woche auf den Straßen von Jerusalem
oder Tel Aviv gegen die Pläne der
Regierung demonstrieren
wir sind hier um den Obersten
Gerichtshof und unser Justizsystem gegen
die Zerstörung zu unterstützen die von
der Regierungskoalition geplant ist sie
plant die Art und Weise wie Israel
regiert wird zu zerstören
tatsächlich plant die Regierung die
Gewaltenteilung grundlegend auszuhebeln
eine Mehrheit der Knesset Abgeordneten
soll Entscheidungen des Obersten
Gerichtshofs über Stimmen dürfen
zugleich will die Regierung mit ihrem
ultra-nationalistischen und ultra
religiösen Mitgliedern die Kontrolle
über die Besetzung der Richter
übernehmen die Auswirkungen wären
dramatisch
die Agenda dieser Koalition insbesondere
der Führer dieser Koalition besteht
darin Israels Demokratie auszulöschen es
wird keine Demokratie mehr existieren
wenn Sie Erfolg haben die
Gewaltenteilung in Israel sichert einzig
und allein der Oberste Gerichtshof wir
haben nichts anderes beseitigen Sie den
und es gibt keine Demokratie mehr
offensichtlich gab es bei der
Staatsgründung 1948 einen weiteren
Geburtsfehler die Gründer um ben-gorion
verzichteten auf manche Checks und
balances der Gewaltenteilung eine
geschriebene Verfassung eine zweite
Kammer ein Verfassungsgericht wie konnte
das passieren trotz der grausamen
Erfahrung des Nationalsozialismus der
hatte die Demokratie demokratisch
abgeschafft
die israelischen Zionisten von damals
dachten sie wären auf irgendeine Weise
immun dagegen wir haben diese Lektion
von draußen so gut gelernt dachten sie
wir waren die Opfer wie um Himmels
willen könnte es auch nur denkbar sein
dass wir den gleichen Fehler begehen
aber das war natürlich eine Fantasie wir
sind alle Menschen und fehlerhaft
und doch hat Israels Demokratie im
Moment größter Not Stärke bewiesen der
demokratische Protest der Straße hat
einen Etappensieg erreicht
die Regierung hat die Umsetzung der
Justizreform ausgesetzt und verhandelt
mit der Opposition die Proteste aber
gehen weiter die Menschen wissen die
Gefahr ist nicht gebannt aber ein Gefühl
gemeinsamer Verantwortung ist entstanden
vielleicht hilft das auch die anderen
Probleme Israels zu lösen
[Musik]